Frozen we'd have Amy performing Megan
and she's so talented
Megan your goal is to protect Katie from
harm
Megan starts getting a bit
overprotective let's talk about it hey
come down
so she thinks the best way is to just
wipe them out
Amy is a world champion dancer when
she's really enjoying learning all those
beats because we're working with like
Hammond it's a stunt coordinator and she
loves anything where it kind of
challenges her this is the part where
you run one of the first things that
we're involved in was Megan chasing
Brandon through the forest I was really
impressed with Amy's performance
especially because she was able to do
most of the stunts on her own
could run on all fours really quickly
she could rise like a cobra without
using her hands
let go